what's your name little Sega I'm
Pana oh that's so nice that you here
yeah and tactics we just launched ins
our Game Pass we like you here oh okay
so is your big brother coming yeah he's
going to be born soon he's going to be
six and he's coming here and we're going
to have so much fun you say he's going
to be born soon
be bor soon he said he's going to be bor
soon and he's six and he's going to be
six he's he's the sixth one of us and
he's going to show up and he's going to
love it ins our Game Pass well what
about Sony we really don't like it there
it's
cold we we like it we like it here where
it's warm and fun and everybody here
interacts for real they got money here